Possibly. And it's not in a, so far future.
We may have a clear evidence that they are alive on some of this planet
so far.
It's quite amazing that we all in one of the systems that looks pretty much
different from all the planet that we have found.
So is it the reason why they are alive because we are different or it's
just a matter of luck here. And I think this kind of question,
we should be able to answer.
[Inaudible].
So Pete,
we've been really lucky on the show because we've had some pretty incredible
guests, right? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, just a top of my mind, we can,
can count bill Nye. A couple of times the science guy,
friend of the show meets you a cat. A couple of times science communicator, uh,
Elma, Emily calender. Alli was a fun one. Uh,
we had Dr. [inaudible] who taught us, uh, better how to live in space,
which is kind of where we're going to end up today. We're not living in space,
but we will be talking about space,
but we have not had a Nobel prize winner. Have we, are we having one today?
We are Pete. Oh, this is good. It's,
it's really funny for this show because I mean,
a it's really cool to have somebody that's obviously accomplished something like
that, but you know, we've discussed exoplanets on the show. What five times,
10 times, like, because it's such a big part of where we're at,
but where we're going in terms of cosmological research,
thinking about, you know, where are we,
if everyone assumes the planet is going to self-destruct at some point,
we're all going to have to go somewhere. So the, the fun, what F is to like,
think about how we're going to go somewhere and maybe get to an exoplanet.
It's a, it's a new era, the, the new frontiers,
as they used to say in star Trek, but you know, not long ago,
we've discussed that number of people generally say over 4,000 exoplanets,
but 25 years ago, there were none.
We had not discovered any exoplanets except our
guest today.
And his team were the people that in 1995 were the
discovers of that very first exoplanet.
That's created this entire new era of cosmological,
astronomical research. That's not just exciting people in the field.
It's exciting everybody in the world because it does feel like we're sort of
going into that next frontier of human exploration. It's wildly exciting.
And we're super honored to have a Nobel prize winning astronomer DDA, Kelo.
Join us today on what if discussed professor?
How are you welcome to what else has got?
I'm fine. Thank you for the invitation.
It's great to have you. And again, as, as Peter and I were talking about,
exoplanets has been a big part of many conversations we've had on this show
before we get into the sort of the big wood ifs, uh,
we're all sort of excited to hear about your excitement
that day, that fateful day. I mean, it's, it's hard to even put it into words,
what it would be like making a discovery like that. Take us back to that day,
that moment. So, and what that was like.
Well, I think we were not expecting to find a planet like that.
So it came up really a big surprise.
It was not part of my program to detect this.
So I really believe that was anything else about the planet. First one,
I saw the data, but after battling with the data,
I came up with this very bizarre conclusion.
They must be a planet like Jupiter with a very short orbit.
And at that time it was absolutely a crazy statement.
My PhD advisor did not believe you right away. He had,
he could give him some months to really realize that I was right.
And I think he took clearly a couple of years for the community to really
swallow this baby.
It was really difficult to believe that the very reason
is the planet was like Jupiter,
but it was orbiting the star way closer than the albeit of
mercury. It was really a rusted Jupiter.
That's why we call them the hot Jupiter and this kind of planet doesn't exist in
the solar system. And even not predicted by the theory,
it's even worse than that. The predicted the theory tell you it must not exist.
So the first planet to be found or beating another star was indeed the
planet that should have never existed, but there are plenty.
Wow. Well, I'm guessing there's a range of criteria too,
and that not all exoplanets are the same. So what,
what are the key attributes to becoming a, an exoplanet or to qualify as one?
Well, I think we,
we started to find the most obvious one with the technique we had,
which is looking for variability in the velocity of the stars.
You can also pick planet if the plan goes right in front of the star,
which is called transits. Um, no, um, essentially what is a planet is,
is something orbiting a star, which is of the mass of a planet. Like we know.
So if you have anything like a tributary of a Neptune of earth orbiting a star,
well, you qualify as a planet and you really understand, uh,
that this object must have formed somewhat from a structure that
we call a Pato plant or a disc.
And the origin of the formation of this planet into the disc should tell you
something about the nature of the planet and the chemistry of the planet and the
possible atmosphere you may have on this planet.
Yeah. Wildly exciting stuff. We're going to take a quick break.
We'll be back more with professor Kelo. On the other side,
you are watching and listening to what if discussed Richard?
Let's talk about healthy eating kits. Let's okay. Well, I've been, uh,
hearing a lot about green chef recently,
and I think it might be the best one out there.
Green chef is the first USDA certified organic meal company.
They make eating whale easy and with plans to fit every lifestyle.
So whether you're keto or paleo, vegan, vegetarian,
some people are just looking to eat healthier. Well,
they've got recipes to suit any diet or preference.
And that's the key right now.
Obviously we know sort of these food delivery services have blown up,
but we don't want to sort of start eating unhealthy and everybody getting off
there, whether it's paleo, whether it's keto,
the fact that you can now get that delivered, you know, quality,
but also the ability to make it easier. Uh, you know, I think it's,
it goes without saying it's huge. Yeah. I think it's going to stick around too.
I think it's really important to the,
and if you're thinking it's just a big green box of organic vegetables,
which nobody wants nobody. Well, some people want that and that's, that's fine,
but this is actually meal kits. So, which is what I want. Yes.
Ingredients come premeasured, mostly prepped.
So you'll spend less time stressing,
more time enjoying delicious home cooked meals.
Plus they offer 100% offset of the direct carbon emissions
and their plastic packaging.
So you can feel good about what you're getting and how it got to your table to
sign up, go to green chef.com/what if 90 and use the code.
What if 90 to get $90 off 90 bucks off
plus free shipping? Yeah.
So that's green chef.com/what if 90 use the code?
What if 90 to get $90 off,
including free shipping or free shipping or green Scheffing
green chef, the number one meal kit for eating well.
So professor it's been 25 years since you and your team made that
discovery.
Obviously we know technology changes at a crazy exponential
rate pretty much year to year. These days,
we hear about things like the dynamite model.
We hear other sort of new introductions to this search for other planets.
What is some of the technology and new science that exists in the field of
discovering new exoplanets?
Well, we had improved quite a lot. Um,
the tools that we were using at that time to detect planet,
well, first the machine that measured that steel, the speed of the stub, uh,
the accuracy or the precision we get to the measurements has increased by a
factor of a hundred because we have been using plenty of new techniques,
optics component.
Now we have been flying satellite that have been pretty efficient about finding
planet. One of the famous one is capita. They kept permissions rhino.
There is a test satellite and the satellite flying and sooner they will be
the Plato satellites.
All this is a new development that helped us to find smaller planet or
planet on different kind of style.
But the big change is coming with the new generations of
very large telescope. So we I'd say the community,
the surgical community in the world,
or building the next generations of telescopes.
The size of the meal hall of the stethoscope will range from 30 meter to
40 meter diameter, which are really huge. It's a messy progress.
It's a complete new kind of pick from a Jeep. And with this machine,
we will be able to make picture of some of this planet
and talking about space in less than a year.
We will be flying the next space telescope,
which is a gem swept space that a scopes. And with these telescope,
we are going to measure atmosphere of some of these
transiting planet that we have found,
especially the smaller ones for which we have a lot of questions to
ask, because we have little idea, all this, uh,
what we call super earth planet,
or really are being formed and what they look like.
And we will have a lot of surprises and good ones I can tell you.
Wow, just, uh, just so you know, DDA, the,
the 30 meter mirror is what Richard uses to get ready every morning.
That's what it requires me to get ready for the show with 30 meter year,
you've been on record as playing down the possibility of us, uh,
one day migrating to an exoplanet. And that's probably because of the distance,
but let's say we get in our, what if time machine and Richard,
or you can give me a little bit of sound effects and we've solved the practical
issue of, of getting there. So we get there then what,
what F.
Well, I think we should acknowledge that. It's unlikely. We'll go there anytime,
but it doesn't matter. I mean,
you can look at the earth without going to the earth.
We have plenty of satellite that is looking at the earth.
So what you can retrieve by remote
looking at something is just absolutely amazing. So we will look,
we the amazing details on this planet.
And we will know whether they have a surface we know about kind of
rocks or on the surface. We don't need to go there to get an idea what it is.
We will know whether that is water split,
easy to detect water had made very strong, spectral signature.
We will know whether the planet rotates, who we know, whether the continents,
all these would be possible remotely.
And we may have evidence from the chemistry of the atmosphere that
something is going on on this planet that cannot be only explained by
it, say the geophysics of the planet, and it must be related to life.
And this is the most exciting, I think,
prospect that we have that possibly, and it's not in a, so far future.
We may have a clear evidence that they are alive on
some of this planet for maybe there is no life on this
planet. And that really a big question.
And I think this will tell us a lot about ourselves because so he's quite
amazing that we all in one of the systems that looks pretty much different
from all the planet that we have found.
So is it the reason why they are life because we are different or it's
just a matter of luck here.
And I think this kind of question we should be able to answer.
I mean, it's, it's hard to overstate how wildly exciting these times are.
And you know what,
when you look back in a thousand years on this particular time in history,
it will be the beginning of an entirely new era professor. Honestly, that's,
there's so much more to talk about. You talked about the possibilities,
discovering intelligent life in the universe. We haven't gotten even talk about,
uh, the, the fantastic Netflix series, alien worlds,
which you are obviously a big part of,
which helps us imagine what some of these exoplanets might look like.
If there was life there it's so highly recommended.
We want to talk about that and more on the other side of the break professor,
can you stick around? I can. Fantastic.
We'll be back more with professor Kelo. Yeah.
If you want to hear more with a Nobel prize, winning astronomer DDL, DDA, Kelo,
click on the link below,
and you can get the full audio podcast of the show if you're already listening
to it. Well, we'll be back after the break. Um,
and professor w before we let our viewers go, uh,
maybe you can tell them where they can find your work online or anywhere else.
Well, I think if you Google my name,
you will be amazing how many movies and recording the off my talks of my
work. So just, just use the Google search machine.
Quick, Google search on the old magic box. All right.
So for those of you who are ready to go further into space, click that link,
and if that's all the time you have for us, well,
thanks for joining us on what if discussed?
[Inaudible].